cardi B is pretty in pink on the March
cover of Harper's Bazaar that's not a
fabulous the 26 year old singer stuns in
the spring fashion issue rocking muumuu
and Vera Wang throughout my fashion
guilty pleasure is spending money but
cardi also gets serious with the mag
revealing her estranged husband off set
wanted to see a counselor to help save
their marriage
after his alleged cheating scandal quote
I decided on my own nobody makes my
decisions about my life but nee I didn't
want to go to marriage counseling he
suggested it but it's like I don't want
to go there's no counselor or nothing
that could make me change my mind
although the pair who shared their
almost seven month old daughter culture
seemed to be working through their
relationship issues as of late cardi and
offset were spotted out together at a
Super Bowl party last week he's changing
diapers but like I've been seeing offset
being a dad he already has three kids so
I already fell in love the way that he
was a dad already I'm like oh my god I
could have a little one with this guy
he's really good cardi also got candid
about postpartum depression after giving
birth to culture I thought I was going
to avoid it I was like well I'm doing
good right now I don't think that's
going to happen but out of nowhere the
world was heavy on my shoulders cardi
had a much different outlook when et
spoke with her while pregnant last May I
want to work I don't know I feel very
energetic to keep on going like powerful
legs
like a woman the new issue of Harper's
Bazaar hits newsstand February 19th